バンキラジオ俺の名前は天才小学生や焼肉
が大好きだお母さん恥ずかしいよあや
ちゃん見つけたわすごお母さん俺焼肉行き
たい今日はご馳
[拍手]
ねお待たせしましたカルビです
[音楽]
焼肉
最高えお母さん食べすぎだよ足りないよ
焼肉は高いので贅沢はダメですあんたの
っこにで単にして食べてやる
あ
[音楽]
くそ焼肉屋さんになれば肉いっぱい
食べれるかもこの生ぬるい根性私が燃やし
じるわ
決めた俺焼肉屋さんに
なる
こら売れる焼肉屋を作らないとまずは勉強
だよし作戦完成
だ秘のタレを作るぞ隠し味に甘みとエを
追加するうまい棒のコンボタを入れるん
だマイルドかパンチのある味に仕上げる
地元身に来てもらって口コミを
広める焼肉の匂いだお腹空いたくくく焼肉
の匂いの中毒性はすごい
ぞここ行きたい初回皿寝よじゃない行く
うん行こ
行こう天才やき焼肉グランですどうぞ
どうぞいらっしゃい
ませお待たせしましたこちらサービスの
鮮度の鉄球カルビです
どうぞお待たせしました
すごい映える
わおいしい良かったじゃんこちらお土産の
天才やチップスですうわあ
面白いおえバ
やねちゃんおお母さん
あららららこんなに石数があるのに1組
しか来なかったのね早いとこ諦めたら
うるさいな赤字ね赤字真っ赤
かまあ初日は赤字でもいいんだここから
SNSでの告知が加速する
はぜん線路の鉄球で役カルビうのも喜びお
土産のポテチもおいしすぎたうんこれは
数字が取れそうです
[音楽]
ねYouTubeどうもですさ今は話題の
焼だっ
た早速行き
ましょう天才屋焼肉さん
手は小学生どうぞ
もあれ偽金じゃないトップ
YouTuberだうおやば楽しみ
楽しみお待たせしました仙の特急カルビ
ですうわあ本物ですうまそう鉄分が香ばし
すぎでは早速いただきますうー
[音楽]
うまマジでうまい家のまるちゃん達にも
食べさせたいな
ンどうぞこちら天才カルビンです
わしました目玉の天才カルビンバ外国さ
和牛をしよう天主自らトッピングすげえ
じゃあ早速いただきたいと思いますバんん
うま
すぎ最後はこちら天才やすきジュースです
ああ来ました僕の音ドリンク天才エネス
ジュースメロンソーダとコーラを1対1だ
と天才になっちゃう
ドリンク行きます
[音楽]
ようますぎお
あ
ああ
[音楽]
ポインツ最初はじゃんけん
だけ飯ぜ
き
たオープンですどうぞいらっしゃいませ
いらっしゃいませどうぞいらっしゃいませ
どうぞ
肉そうSNSでバを見これでもう集客には
困ら
ないライスになり
ますご飯大盛りですかううやばいこれ
やばい美しいね良かったねおいしぱおいし
うまえうま才から丁はいよはい才から
あありよっますうわ絶対ちゃうわいただき
ますおいしいおいしい
おいしいダクトビ甘い
よありがとうございましたありがとう
ありがとうござい美しかったですました
おしかったおも美味しかったまた来ね
[音楽]
たまねふ終わった終わっ
た平見後
はまかない焼肉
[音楽]
最高うん
おいしい
あまお金も稼げて焼肉も止めるて最高だ
やね
ちゃん
お母さんこの店の権利は私がもらうわそれ
俺の金だろしかもお母さんは関係ないだろ
そもそも小学生が見せあるには保護者の
協力が必要なのよそうだけど大丈夫安心し
て私がこのお店の肉も人気も火をつけて
あげる
わ任せなさいは
[音楽]
秘伝のタレを作るわ
よ隠し味に猛毒を入れて苦を追加する
[音楽]
のチコ焼き肉大店であれお店変わったのあ
ちょっとだけ
ねはいどうぞ
何この
ポスターこの店の看板娘ビジンキーコの
ポスターよ癒されるでしょはははいどうぞ
キーコカルピ
ですこの肉腐ってるわやめてちょうだい
うえまずちょっと肉の前にご飯出して
ちょうだいあ
はいはい真っ黒ご飯ですどうぞ
べマはい新鮮な肉はねえのかよあー新鮮な
肉ねそうだちょっと待って
なさいいい
た
バーよし
レックスカルビです皆さん
[音楽]
[拍手]
召し上がれそしたらお口のしのお土産の
ポテチ
ですう
ポイントマイナス
100そあんた引けすぎれでしょが
[音楽]
す
度とるかとるかこれお金払なお金お金払な
よお金
度きなさいよちょっとちょっとあなたたし
なさい
よだよね
もうシクシク
シクシク一生懸命作ったのに誰も私のお肉
食べてくれないわシクシク
[音楽]
シシ
ややね
ちゃんあれねこんなに石があるのに誰も来
てない
じゃんもう諦めたらあだねまか
かは毎回こうなるよなごめんねいつも邪魔
して悪い親よねいいよお母さん一緒に焼肉
やろうえ手伝ってくれる
もう1回この焼肉をそうぜキコ焼肉の復活
に向けて燃え尽きるまで頑張る
ぞ
[音楽]
ガガガのお母さん玉TKGです
[拍手]
おちゃんやったわねじゃんじゃん次のやる
わよお次はファイアーカルビです皆さん
危ないので下がっておいてください
お母さん行け
あちゃん次もどんどんやるわよお母さん次
はこっちよいしょほらみんなみ
[音楽]
ら早
早やけたやけたこれが本当のみのきこ焼肉
だね
あああんたもってやるわ
さちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネルトロ
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしく最はチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録